siakam one-on-one coverage with draymond
Green I smoked inside stop help doesn't
come all away go get to your spot any
beach trip six on the 24 Lowry gets a
good look for siakam hope connects 16
first ci comme ci comme has been good
play by Kyle our little driving kick
it's a wide-open siakam running the
floor see action back to water and gets
the roll
why Leonard grimaces a bit as he gets up
on a slight hitch in his gait as he runs
up the floor Steph Curry gets away from
the defense nice feed inside a Gazala
Bell block pass by C Aachen
it's a tough catch drop off past to
Linnet they go down low for three from
downtown see Ockham drives hard well
defended and he still thanks at home
he's got 20 Raptors have done a great
job in transition and see Ockham getting
to his right hand takes a little bump
this good defense but incredibly hope
but they are not a better basketball
team without Kevin Durant what he does
is makes life so much easier for
everybody in a beautiful Matt pass from
curry say I come with a finish down the
other end he's got 10 points in the
corner timeout Golden State siakam with
4 on the clock Roscoe
this shot rattles around and through
he's having a massive night is staying
in front of klay Thompson getting him
out of River Murray tried to draw
contact again at the shot clock here
comes the aquam sidestepped lamp it's
good wow what a quarter for siakam not
matter who's in front of him he is
having his way aggressive with his foot
on a gas pedal and making big-time
offensive plays and what agility to
sidestep